Babe, hurry up.  I'm hungry.
What is your passcode!?
Who is Kara!?
You think I wont find out?
You disgust me.
Hey sorry that took so long.
Well well well, if it isn't the sexting king himself.
You're trying to go through my phone?
Can I get you anything Matt?
A cup of coffee?
Uh, no thanks.
It's FRESH!
Haha, I'm just kidding.  I wouldn't do that.
You can't do this okay?  I have rights.
Your friend flipped on you, Matt.
He told me all about Kara.
Celly wouldn't do that.
Hm.  Just tell me you had a sextext with Kara.
I'm sure we can work this whole thing out.
She's a nobody, okay?
Listen.
I can get the DA to agree to three weeks on the couch.
Potentially, Poker Night parole.
But you've got to give me something to work with.
Kara is just a co-worker, okay?
It's strictly platonic!
I swear!
WHAT IS THIS?
The home shopping network!?
Because I'm not buying.
You know, you probably shouldn't be going through my phone.
I'LL ASK THE QUESTIONS!
First of all, that wasn't even a question!
Second of all, if you had anything on me
I would already be getting the silent treatmet.
Aw, Matt, Matt, Matt.
I didn't want to do this.
What--what are you doing with that?
Oh, you know.  Just swinging it around.
And causing chaos.
That's a limited edition!  Please be careful!
It can all be yours if you just give me that passcode.
Tik tock, Matt.
Oh!  Oh!
3 seconds left before I smash it on the ground!
Three.  Two.
Times up!
Okay okay!  69 69!
You're pathetic.
Where am I?
Text: "Hey Matt, just a reminder that all expense receipts need to be scanned into a pdf document."
I love you, babe.
We need to talk.